une dernière question un peu plus
politiques posés par radio j
dans la perspective du déconfinement
certains s'interrogent sur l'état de vos
relations avec emmanuel macron notamment
parce que vous n'avez pas toujours
utilisé les mêmes termes dans vos
message adressé aux français
confirmez-vous des tensions voire des
désaccords avec le président de la
république dans le cadre de la gestion
de la crise et dans la manière
d'envisager le déconfinement a je crois
que je vais vous décevoir
enfin décevoir celui qui pose la
question depuis trois ans qu'il m'a été
donné de pouvoir travailler avec le
président de la république en tant que
chef de gouvernement
j'ai toujours eu dans nos relations
constater il me réjouir d'une confiance
d'une fluidité qui je crois a peu de
précédents
et voilà c'est toujours le cas et
j'espère que ce sera toujours le cas et
je crois que ce sera toujours le cas
mais permettez moi de vous dire
permettez moi de vous dire que dans les
moments que nous vivons en plein dans
une crise sanitaire d'une ampleur
considérable alors que des françaises et
des français font un travail incroyable
pour sauver leurs concitoyens passé plus
de deux secondes à écrire à parler à
s'interroger sur ce genre de sujet
meules est très très circonspect et je
pense que nos concitoyens s'en
contrefichent dans des proportions qu à
mon avis les journalistes politiques ne
mesure pas et je dois dire que de ce
point de vue là je me sens très français
je vous remercie